A key concept in this course,
we'll be lifecycle.
So these are the different lifecycle stages,
material extraction,
material processing,
manufacturing use,
and we'll call it waste management.
Ideally,
we'll,
we'll talk about ways of,
we're not talking about end of life,
but rather closing loops.
Why is life cycle thinking going to be absolutely essential to,
uh,
green chemistry discussion as sustainability discussion?
Let's go through it.
Uh,
so,
oh,
when we look at the origins of our feedstocks,
it would be very possible to produce a product that is nontoxic,
affective,
performs great.
You know,
a little kid could chew on it,
no problem,
but yet do it in a way that results in dramatic ecological damage.
But you might say that that's a,
that's a rarity right now.
That's pretty much the,
the rule of the road.
What did we say about the amount of,
uh,
of waste generated per,
per pound of product for manufacturing generally?
Yeah.
So we're talking about 90% of all of the material that goes into manufacturing
winds up immediately his weight.
And it's the character,
not the amount,
the character,
the nature of the inherent nature of those materials.
That is crucially important.
Is it to pleading?
Is it renewable?
Is it inherently toxic?
All right,
so we know what manufacturing is,
is a conversion of raw materials into products.
So looking at the design and the production of goods and
manufacturing needs to add value in order for it to be really considered
manufacturing.
Although there are a lot of businesses that it's very questionable.
Um,
so is manufacturing important?
These are the different industry sectors and this is a billion tons of waste.
Waste generated manufacturing waste are significant to say the least.
When you take a look at the annual waste generator,
this is a EU data.
Uh,
uh,
manufacturing wastes are,
are significant,
but these other,
uh,
Eric,
now a quick aside,
energy production,
very little waste,
1%.
What does that mean?
It means,
and we'll talk about this,
that the petrochemical industry is one of the most materially efficient
industries that the world has ever seen.
Almost.
If you only got a 99% efficiency for many of the petrochemical processes,
you'd be fired.
You'd be shut down,
it'd be out of business.
The degree to which they are so excellent at efficiency and can say,
oh,
well good then that,
then that's perfect.
That's why we talk about life cycle because it's not all about efficiency.
It's not all about one life cycle stage.
Okay.
What about the use phase?
They say,
Oh,
I'm,
I meet a washing machine and I made it from a,
from a new barrel renewable resin and I,
and I'm going to recycle the whole thing.
Where's the impact?
Was the environmental impact,
uh,
of a,
of a washing machine.
It's in the use phase,
the energy consumed in the use and the water consumed in the US,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
okay.
What about,
um,
is use important?
Think about those products where they use is of necessity.
Discipline of,
remember I laws of thermodynamics.
Chlorofluorocarbons,
whether it's in sprays or or whatever it is,
propellant.
These will wind up in the ozone layer.
Solvents wide range of solvents are amongst the highest,
uh,
emissions,
air emission,
uh,
chemicals known coolin's.
Pesticides and fertilizers necessarily have to be distributed in the environment
to function.
It's why they wind up in our groundwater.
It's why they wind up in our drinking water.
Okay.
Is End of life important?
Yeah,
it kind of speaks for itself,
I guess.
Yeah.
That's the base camp of the Himalayas.
Anybody want to go for a track?
All right.
Okay.
So we need to have lifecycle thinking.
This is not a life cycle analysis class.
We're not going to do a rigorous lifecycle analysis,
lagers,
rigorous lifecycle assessment.
However,
if we don't think across lifecycle,
then we will do exactly the wrong things by shifting the problem from one life.
So locals lifecycle stage to another,
and you're going to find them.
That is so often the essence of greenwashing.